[Musique]
journal de bord les passagers sont
montés à bord en croyant sincèrement que
ce serait le plus beau voyage de leur
vie
comme il se trompait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vraiment magnifique
nicolas vazquez premier officiel du
barbara dorey lance deux êtres
mesdemoiselles villanueva
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant cette obscurité et
qu'on finit par en tomber amoureux
un homme à la mer à bâbord monsieur
il ya une bagarre au moins deux
personnes sont entrées c'est flagrant
cette femme n'est pas tombé à l'eau
accident ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle
cherche à quelque chose il ya un
assassin sur ce navire l'accès au reste
du navire vous ai strictement restreint
[Applaudissements]
alors on se remet à plus tard
je risque gros à ce voyage car les nains
je vois que tu ne met pas des yeux
[Musique]
ça peut arriver
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains secrets sont encore plus
profond que l'océan
[Musique]